اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في تونس يتواصل
الجدل بشان ما عرف بالكتاب الاسود وهو
كتاب اصدرته رئاسه الجمهوريه التونسيه
وكشف ما اعتبره تورط اعلاميين ورجال ثقافه
ووسائل اعلام تونسيه واجنبيه في الحصول
على اموال مقابله تلميع صوره نظام زين
العابدين بن علي نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في
محورين ما هي الحدود الفاصله بين المشروع
وغير المشروع في علاقه الاعلاميين بنظام
سياسي
ما وكيف السبيل لمنع شراء ذمم الكوادر
القادره على التاثير في سياق بناء انظمه
سياسيه جديده تقطع مع
الماضي منذ خروج خروج اولى التسريبات الى
العلن في تونس قبل عده ايام والجدل بشان
الكتاب الاسود لم ينقطع فبينما راى فيه
البعض غيضا من فيض في حق الشعب في معرفه
من شاركوا في تضليله تحفظ اخرون على مضمون
الكتاب والطريقه التي اعد بها بيد ان
الجدل بشان الكتاب الاسود التونسي اثار
بدوره جدلا اوسع بشان علاقه الاعلاميين
بالانظمه السياسيه وس لضبط هذه العلاقه
بحيث يظل الاعلام اداه تخدم المجتمع عوض
ان يتحول الى عصا في يد الانظمه كما حدث
في تونس بن علي
مثلا الكلهم بك فرحانين يا ابو تونس
لحنين يقولوا لك احنا
زين كان هذا حال اغلب وسائل الاعلام
التونسي في عهد الرئيس المخلوع بن علي
تطبل وتغني وتمجد وتهلل للديكتاتور لم يقف
الدور عند ذلك الحد بل وصل الامر بالبعض
الى حد الوشايه بالمعارضين وكتابه
التقارير جاءت الثوره
لتجبلى ارشيف وكاله الاتصال الخارجي التي
كانت تلمع صوره النظام السابق وتسوقه
اشلاء ملقه على قارعه الطريق تنفس الكثير
من المورثين مع الدكتاتوريه السعداء مع
تلك الخط
ليعودوا الى تصدر واجهه المشهد الاعلامي
الجديد لكن المفاجاه جاءت هذه الايام مع
اصدار رئاسه الجمهوريه للكتاب الاسود كتاب
يفضح دواليب منظومه اعلاميه كامله كان
يحركها نظام بن علي يتضمن الكتاب وصفا
للارشيف الذي عثر عليه بالقصر الرئاسي
ويذكر اسماء المتعاونين مع النظام السابق
من صحفيين ومثقفين بل ويذكر حتى المبالغ
الماليه التي كانوا يحصلون عليها لم يمر
اصدار الكتاب في صمت فقد اثار ضجه وجدلا
واسعا في الوسط الاعلامي وحتى السياسي
استحسن البعض صدوره فيما هاجمه كثيرون
اخرون لكل اسبابه منهم من بات يخشى ان
يفضح تاريخه مع النظام السابق ومنهم من
يحذر من امكانيه سوء استخدام المعلومات
التي وردت فيه لتشويه صحفيين شرفاء وتصفيه
حسابات شخصيه اما نقابه الصحفيين فقد
اعتبرت ان في الامر توظيفا سياسيا من قبل
رئيس الجمهوريه مشدده على ضروره التعامل
مع الارشيف في اطار العداله الانتقاليه
حافظ مريب ح لبرنامج ما وراء الخبر
الجزيره
تونس ضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه من تونس
الدكتور جمال الزرن استاذ الاعلام في معهد
الصحافه وعلوم الاخبار بالجامعه التونسيه
وهنا في الاستديو الكاتب والصحفي وائل
القنديل اهلا بك بضيفي نبدا من تونس
والدكتور جمال
الزرن كمنظومه نظام شمولي هل هناك اي شيء
في هذا الكتاب الاسود ما يفاجئ
حقيقه
لا اكيد يعني الكتاب مهما يكن نتحدث في في
الكواليس عن وجود منظومه يعني اعلاميه
واخطبوط اعلامي لكن عندما نجد المساله
موثقه ومن صوره يختلف في الامر يعني وليست
مساله يعني تسريبات وانما هذه يعني وثائق
موثقه وارقام والى غير ذلك وبالفعل شيء
مفزع كان ذلك على المستوى الداخلي او كان
ذلك على مستوى الشبكه
الاخطبوط الخارجيه وهنا نتساءل معناها كيف
كان يتنفس المجتمع بالفعل ويعني كيف يمكن
الحديث عن ديمقراطيه وعن حريات وعن مجال
عمومي امام هذا
هذا الاستبداد انصح التعبير ب باهم عنصر
في التطور والتحديث والتنميه الا هو وسائل
الاعلام الا هي الصحافه الا هي حريه
التعبير وحريه الراي هذا الوقود الحيوي
لاي تقدم وي تطور يعني اكتشفنا انه كان
يعني سمسره وبيع وشراء
ويعني معناها مسائل يعني بالفعل تصدم كان
ذلك على مستوى الشبكه المحليه او كان ذلك
على الشبكه الدوليه من من مثقفين ويعني
كتاب وصحفيين الان الكتاب هو يعني بين
ايدي المجتمع وبين ايدي المجتمع المدني
والمهنيين ورجال السياسه العنصر الاضافي
هذا يجب ان يتحول الى بالفعل حوار وجدل
اجتماعي قوي وهام جدا ويجب ان ناخذ في
المستوى الاول ليس مع ام ضد الكتاب وانما
هي الدروس المستقاه كذلك على المستوى
السلبي او الايجابي بالفعل هناك العديد من
الهنات كذلك يتعلق الامر بالمسائل الشخصيه
و بالمسائل الحميميه هذا يعني بالفعل ليس
سياقه اكيد الطريقه التي اشتغل بها على
الكتاب تترك اكثر من تساؤل لكن دعنا من
هذا لكن ايضا اليوم الرساله الاساسيه
هي ولا شخص ولا اي مجموعه بالامكان ان
تستطيع ان تعيد هذه المنظومه في في
المستقبل والا فان ما الها الكشف الان نرى
النموذج التونسي ونتسائل كيف هو حجم
الوثائق مثلا في عهد صدام حسين او في عهد
القدافي او في
يعني هذه اليه كانت تشتغل بها الانظمه
العربيه مجتمعه وهي يعني 80% مما تسوقه
وسائل الاعلام هو اجندات
للانظمه ويعني عبر الهاتف وعبر يعني فرض
يعني عناوين الصحف الاولى وعناوين الاخبار
وان ما كان ينشر هو نوع من انواع القهر
والتظليل الفكري واغتصاب العقول باتم
معن تاكي تاكيدا لهذه الفكره دكتور سيد
وائل قنديل ربما تونس فوجئت لانها معلومات
نشرت يعني ربما هذا الحدث غير
مسبوق هل تعتقد بان طبيعه العلاقه بين
السلطه السياسيه الشموليه في البلاد
العربيه
وال المنظومه الاعلاميه هي تقريبا تكاد
تكون مشتركه في اكثر من دوله وليس تونس
فقط بالتاكيد
يعني اينما وجد استبداد سياسي
وجد فساد اعلامي في الممارسه الاعلاميه و
وليس من المصادفه ان كل اوجه الفساد
الاعلامي مرتبطه دائما بانظمه شموليه
بانظمه مستبده بانظمه قمعيه وكما تفضل
الضيف من تونس وذكر نموذج صدام حسين ثم
نموذج نماذج عديده للغايه
منها دول في الخليج ومعمر القذافي و و كل
ذلك هو البيئه الخ خصبه لافساد الاعلام
اذا اضفنا الى ذلك ان في الانظمه
الاستبداديه الشموليه بالاساس الاعلام ليس
شيئا منفصلا عن السلطه السياسيه بل ان
السلطه السياسيه هي التي تختار وتعين
رؤساء التحرير و ورؤساء القنوات ورؤساء
المحطات التلفزيونيه وكل ذلك فبالتالي لن
نندهش كثيرا اذا وجدنا كل هذه الوثائق
المنشوره ولكن اسمح لي يعني لماذا لماذا
دائما التعاطي مع الاعلام او الصحافه ك ك
حيطه كما يقال يعني في اي نظام سواء
في تونس او غيره كان هناك اعلاميون فاسدون
ورجال اعلام ورجال اعمال وقضاه ومحامون
وغيرهم لماذا المسارعه بتقديرك لكشف هؤلاء
وكانهم هم من يدفع الثمن في اي مرحله من
المراحل الانتقال السياسي يعني شوف هو
الكتاب
نقل المحكي والمتداول في الاروقه وفي
الكواليس الى وثائق ربما يكون هناك اعتراض
على الشكل ولكن من حيث المضمون لا اعتراض
على الاطلاق من حيث الشكل ما كان يعني في
تصوره ما كان ينبغي لمؤسسه الرئاسه
التونسيه ان تقوم بنشر هذا الكتاب كان
بالامكان ان تحيل هذه الوثائق والمستندات
الى اجهزه التحقيق في الدوله لكي يصدر
القضاء حكمه ولكي تاخذ العداله مجراها
ولكن من حيث المضمون كان لابد ربما تاخرت
هذه الخطوه كثيرا وهذا ما ما دفعنا فيه
ثمنا باهظا في مصر كان منذ البدايه
التساؤل هنا لماذا لم تبادر السلطات
التونسيه بالكشف عن هذه عن كشف عن هذا
الفساد مبكرا للغايه في اعقاب سقوط نظام
بن علي لماذا تاخرت كل هذا الوقت هذه
واحده اما من الحث المضموم فهذا جيد
للغايه يعني يعني فكره ان
يمضي الفاسد او بجريمته او بخطيئته فهذا
لا لا يجوز اخلاقيا ولا ليس من العدل هو
هو اللافت اللافت للنظر اللافت للنظر
دكتور جمال الزرن ان ال المطلع على هذا
الكتاب يلاحظ بان هذه المنظومه لا تتعلق
فقط بصحفي ورجال ثقافه وغيره من تونس ال
القصه تمتد الى قنوات عربيه بعضها يقدم
نفسه على انه ممانع و
ومقاوم امتدت الى كتاب وصحفيين في لبنان
في مصر في في الاردن في فلسطين هل تعتقد
بان هذا الاخطبوت
الممتد كان مفاجئا لتونس وبعضها كان يتعلق
حتى بنشر كتب تمجد بن علي
ونظامه بالفعل هي كانت منظومه يعني على
المستوى المحلي وعلى المستوى الدولي في
الدول المتقدمه والديمقراطيه يستعمل
الاعلام في ما يمكن نطلق عليه بالبابل
دبلوماسي يعني في في العلاقات العامه
والدبلوماسيه من اجل التسويق لاقتصاد
الدوله من اجل
يعني مشاريع وبيع يعني اشياء مثل فرنسا
تريد ان تبيع الى الصين وذلك تستعمل يعني
ترثه الاعلاميه لكن العكس نحن نستعمل
وسائل الاعلام الاجنبيه والخارجيه من اجل
التشريع ويعني للاستبداد في الداخل وهذا
يعني هذه المفارقه ليس عيب ان نوظف وسائل
الاعلام الاجنبيه لكن من اجل اي هدف من
اجل اي غايه الاشكال هو ان نشتري ذمم ل
اناس او وسائل اعلام اجنبيه كان ذلك عبر
يعني الاشهار خاصه الاشهار والاعلان وايضا
عبر يعني الضيافات وعبر العلاقات العامه
وعبر يعني اشكال فاسده يعني معروفه
تقليديا لكن ماذا اعطى ل المواطن التونسي
كل هذه المصاريف من المال العام التونسي
ماذا قدمت على المستوى الاقتصادي ماذا
قدمت على المستوى لم تقدم اي شيء الا فقط
يعني تلميع صوره النظام وتنمي صوره خاصه
يعني يعني راس
النظام بالتحديد وهذا هو هو المزعج وهذا
هو الخطير وهذا يعتبر يعني نوع من انواع
يعني الاغتصاب للمال العام وايضا
ل توجيه الراي العام الاجنبي من اجل
الحفاظ على امتيازات السلطه الحاكمه هنا
ونعرف ان الى اخر رمق الى اخر رمق في هذا
النظام لم تتجرا عديد وسائل الاعلام
الاجنبيه يعني حتى المحايده الى نقد
النظام او الى يعني القيام بتقارير يعني
استقصائيه او يعني تعلن عن فشل النظام و
عن يعني الازمه التي كان يتخبط فيها نعم
فاصل قصير مشاهدينا الكرام ونناقش بعده
امكانيه منع استغلال الاعلام في دعم
وتلميع صوره الانظمه الاستبداديه نرجو ان
تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذ
هذه الحلقه التي نتناول فيها دور الاعلام
في دعم الدكتاتوريات في البلاد العربيه في
ضوء صدور ما يسمى الكتاب الاسود في تونس
سيد وائل ال
قنديل الحقيقه قد يجادل البعض انه لكل عهد
مدحوه وطبال وه يعني ما كشف في عهد بن علي
قد ينطبق على حتى تونس ما بعد الثوره او
حتى مصر ما بعد الثوره او حتى في الوقت
الحالي لكل نظام سياسي مادحه ف ربما
يتساءل البعض اين الاشكال ان ان يكون هناك
موقف سياسي لانسان او لرجل ثقافه او اعلام
مؤيد للنظام طالما كان بعيد عن منظومه
فساد او مقابل مالي او غيره لا غضض على
الاطلاق في ذلك من حق اي صحفي ان ينحاز
الى منظومه قيم سياسيه يسلك او يعمل وفقها
اي نظام سياسي ولكن عندما يتحول ذلك الى
وسيله للتربح ووسيله للتكسب يعني اليوم
مثلا في مطار القاهره تم القاء القبض على
رئيس تحرير مصري سابق لتهربه من لمطلوب
ضبطه واحضاره امام جهاز الكسب غير المشروع
والرجل بسلاسه شديده سدد مليون جنيه كفاله
لكي يخلى سبيله في يعني لابد ان نتساءل
هنا اذا كانت هذه الملايين من اين لك هذا
يعني انا اتذكر بعد ثوره 25 يناير احد
رؤساء تحرير الذين كانوا يسبحون ليلا
ونهارا حسني مبارك وجمال مبارك احيل الى
جهاز الكسب غير المشروع في واقعه شهيره
جدا فيلات وقصور وما الى ذلك الرجل ا يعني
انا اندهشت عندما عرض ان يسدد او يتصالح
مع جهاز الكسب غير المشروع دافعا يعني عده
ملايين من من الجنيهات المصريه نحن نعلم
ان هناك اشكاليه ونشكو جميعا في مصر من
تدني اجور الصحافه والصحفيين وما الى ذلك
لابد ان يتساءل هنا يعني كما نقول ان ليس
لس الاعلام هو الحيطه الواطيه لا ينبغي
كذلك ان يكون الاعلام على راسه ريشه يعني
من فسد من تربح من تكسب لابد ان يحسب ولا
بد ان يقرص يعني هي قيمه هذا الكتاب انه
يقرص والمفارقه مثلا ان الاسماء المصريه
المذكوره في هذا الكتاب هي ذاتها الاسماء
التي تؤيد انقلاب 30 يونيو الان يعني هم
هم على الاستبداد حيثما وجد هم على
الاستبداد في كل وقت لا ليس فقط في مصر
يعني الوطني والعربي والد الاستبداد في كل
وقت وفي كل مكان يعني هم عابرون للحدود في
ولكن ولكن من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى يعني ما
الذي يضمن الدكتور جمال الزرن ان ان لا
تتكرر مسائل من هذا القبيل يعني الان في
تونس هناك صحافه صفراء ربما تكون العا مما
كانت عليه في فتره بن علي
وشتائم وسباب ما الذي يضمن ان هؤلاء ايضا
ليسوا مرتبطين بنظام الحكم الجديد وقد
تكون
لهم خباياهم التي قد تكشف
لاحقا اكيد يعني اي نظام سياسي يريد ان
يستهوي ويريد ان يؤثر في المشهد الاعلامي
لكن لمصلحه من هل لمصلحه عامه الناس ام
لمصلحه فويه خاصه هم لمصلحه يعني الدوله
الاستراتيجي ام لمصالح فئويه خاصه فاشك ان
في الانظمه العربيه هو ان
80% من مخرجات وسائل الاعلام هو بفعل
السياسي في حين ان في الانظمه الديمقراطيه
100% من مخرجات الاعلام هو منفعل صحفي
اليوم نريد ان نقلب المعادله يجب على
السياسي ان يحترم هذا العنصر الجديد في
الانتقال الديمقراطي وفي العمليه السياسيه
وهو حريه التعبير عن الراي وحريه وسائل
الاعلام اذا انا اعتبر بان اول شخص يجب ان
يترك الاعلامي تطور مع تطور المجتمع هو
السياسي اي ان يكون مسؤول وان يوفر
الحسنات والضمانات الدستوريه والاخلاقيه
والماديه ايضا والتكنولوجيه ليشتغل
الاعلام بشكل مستقل اكيد توجد يعني اليات
ل يعني ولوبيات ويتحول الاعلام الى قوه
ضغط هذا مشروع في اي ديمقراطيه ولكن في
خدمه الصالح العام وتكون الحكومه هنا او
السياسيون يعني عنصر تعديلي يعدلون اذا
يعني خرج الاعلام يعني في في كشف اثار امن
الدوله او في المس من وحده المجتمع يعدل
السياسي الحكيم والرصين يعني في اتجاه ان
يحافظ على وحده المجتمع وسلامته وخاصه
امنه القومي والاستراتيجي الاشكال ان هذه
المعادله غايبه كليا واليوم اصبح في تونس
الاعلام كما كان في الماضي اداه من ادوات
اداره الصراع اصبح الان اداه من ادوات
اداره الصراع السياسي الاعلام يجب ان يكون
في هذا في هذا السياق دكتور في هذا السياق
دكتور البعض يتهم حتى رئاسه الجمهوريه في
تونس بانها بصدد تصفيه حسابات مع قطاع
الاعلام كيف يمكن ان نناى بهذه الشبهه عن
مجال يفترض ان تعرف عنه الحقائق لكن ضمن
سياق بعيد عن اتهامات من هذا
القبيل في تونس سيدي الكريم في تونس كل من
كل طرف سياسي كانت له ورقه ضغط الاعلام ام
المجلس
مجلس النواب او المجلس التاسيسي او الشارع
كل انسان كانت له كانت بين يديه ورقه
استغلها وهذا الاشكال لكن الاعلام له صبغه
خصوصيه لا يمكن ان ظف لانه ملك ويعكس كل
ما في المجتمع التونسي من تعدد وتنوع لذلك
علينا ان نناى بكل التجاذب السياسي على
المشهد الاعلامي لانه فيه يعني نحتضن
الانتقال الديمقراطي ويجب ان نعكس هذا
التعدد والتنوع والصراع الاجتماعي الموجود
في تونس الانتقال الديمقراطي دخل وسائل
ولكن ه ه هل من السهل هل من السهل هل من
السهل ان نناى بالاعلام سيد وائل قنديل عن
التجاذبات السياسيه يعني عمليه مستحيله
تقريبا يعني اذا كنا نتحدث عن ثورات ربيع
عربي وعن تغيير جذري في في المفاهيم ومبدا
الفصل بين السلطات لابد ان يكون الاعلام
مستقلا عن السلطه السياسيه كما يحدث في كل
دول العالم المتحضر ولكن المشكله الحقيقيه
ان النظم العربيه تتعامل مع اجهزه الاعلام
دائما على انها مجرد خادمات في بلاطها هي
مكمله لهذه السلطه وبالتالي كان من
المنتظر بعد هذه الثورات ان يكون الاعلام
هو اعلام الشعب يعني الاعلامي لا يقل دوره
ولا تقل اهميته عن دور القاضي في المجتمع
هو عين المجتمع هو الذي يحقق العداله في
الحصول على المعلومه كما يحقق القاضي
العداله في الحصول على الحقوق القانونيه
والحقوق الماديه وبالتالي
ا كان هذا هو المامول بعد ثوره 25 يناير
اننا يعني كنا بصدد واعددنا العديد من
المشروعات الخاصه بتنظيم مهنه الاعلام
بحيث يكون مستقلا عن اي سلطه سياسيه ولكن
للاسف الشديد كل كل هذا ذهب ادراج الرياح
واكرر مره اخرى ان الاعلاميين الذين قامت
ضدهم ثوره 25 يناير هم الذين كانوا الاداه
المستخدمه في انقلاب 30 يونيو هذه ليست
مصادفه شكرا جزيلا لك السيد وائل قنديل
الكاتب والصحفي المصري شكرا لضيفنا من
تونس الدكتور جمال الزرن استاذ الاعلام في
معهد الصحافه بهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله والى
اللقاء
ان